TIMOTHY JORDAN: Good
day, I'm Timothy Jordan.
And this week I'm speaking to
you from Sydney, Australia.
This is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
TensorFlow Serving is a
high-performance serving system
for machine learning
models designed
for production environments.
And version 1.0
is now available.
Also included in this
release is a pre-built binary
available through apt-get
install, which is really cool.
For more info on the release
and on using TensorFlow Serving,
check out the post linked
in the description below.
Google is proud to
be a platinum sponsor
of the 34th International
Conference on Machine Learning,
taking place this week
right here in Sydney.
There's over 130 Googlers
attending the conference
to present publications
and host workshops.
But as usual, don't worry
if you didn't attend.
Just head on over to
the post for links
to the papers and
workshops we're presenting.
Version 2.0 of the
Nearby Connections API
is now available, providing a
high bandwidth, low latency,
encrypted data transfers
between nearby devices
in a fully offline
peer-to-peer manner.
Release details, as well as
links to the docs and code,
are on the post.
Chrome 61 now
exposes an estimate
of how much storage
a web app is using
and how much is available.
For some code and a discussion
on how to use this in your app,
take a look at the post.
Conditional REST
requests are now
available for the Firebase
Realtime Database.
You can use them to safely
perform atomic operations,
and you can get
started with the post.
The day before
GopherCon 2017, a group
of Go team members
and contributors
gathered in Denver to discuss
the plan for the future
of the Go project.
The discussions covered
compiler and runtime,
dependency management, the
standard library, and much,
much more.
For a detailed
overview of the day,
check out the post linked
in the description below.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
Thanks for tuning into this
week's episode of The Developer
Show.
To catch some of our
previous episodes,
they're right over here.